found this really fantastic ronald
reagan's speech this is a video of
ronald reagan warning us of government
overreach and appeasement take a look
no government ever voluntarily reduces
itself in size so government programs
once launched never disappear
actually a government bureau is the
nearest thing to eternal life we'll ever
see on this earth
what does it mean whether you hold the
deed
to the or the title to your business or
property if the government holds the
power of life and death over that
business or property and such machinery
already exists the government can find
some charge to bring against any concern
it chooses to prosecute
every businessman has his own tale of
harassment
somewhere a perversion has taken place
our natural unalienable rights are now
considered to be a dispensation of
government
and freedom has never been so fragile so
close to slipping from our grasp as it
is at this moment
now let's set the record straight
there's no argument over the choice
between peace and war
but there's only one guaranteed way you
can have peace and you can have it in
the next second
surrender
admittedly there's a risk in any course
we follow other than this but every
lesson of history tells us
that the greater risk lies in
appeasement and this is the specter our
well-meaning liberal friends refuse to
face that their policy of accommodation
is appeasement
and it gives no choice between peace and
war only between fight or surrender if
we continue to accommodate continue to
back and retreat
eventually we have to face the final
demand the ultimatum and what then
you and i know and do not believe that
life is so dear and peace so sweet has
to be purchased at the price of chains
and slavery
if nothing in life is worth dying for
when did this begin
just in the face of this enemy
or should moses have told the children
of israel to live in slavery under the
pharaohs
should christ have refused the cross
should the patriots at concord bridge
have thrown down their guns and refused
to fire the shot heard round the world
the martyrs of history were not fools
and our honored dead who gave their
lives to stop the advance of the nazis
didn't die in vain
where then is the road to peace
well it's a simple answer after all
you and i
have the courage to say to our enemies
there is a price we will not pay there
is a point beyond which they must not
advance
man chills up my spine and i am sure i'm
not only speaking for myself that sort
of clarity that sort of honesty that
sort of
decency
from a good man who didn't want to rule
your life just wanted to create the
conditions so you could rule it yourself
i mean there's a couple incredible
quotes there that i think ring pretty
freaking true today what does it mean
whether you hold the deeter title to
your business or property if the
government
holds the power of life and death over
that business or property does that
sound familiar over the last couple
years does that sound familiar
and by appeasement what he's talking
about
is that we keep giving we keep giving oh
no no if you just stay at home if you
just wear a mask if you just get
injected if you just stay on the
government dole because they're not
letting you go to work just more and
more and more and it's just kind of
small and we're just going to appease
and appease and peace and appeasement
doesn't work right ask neville
chamberlain about that hitler guy and
that's sort of where we're all at at the
moment we've appeased we've played this
thing was crazy two years ago we didn't
know what was happening as i said
yesterday it's like i grant everybody
that first month of kovid we all get a
pass we all got to pass it was so crazy
did a few people were there a few voices
out there like no if we start with
lockdowns and masks and everything else
this will go to a horrible place yes i
think i roughly warned about that
doesn't matter it doesn't matter anymore
everyone gets a pass at the beginning
but now it's time no more appeasement no
more appeasement make a decision no more
surrender do you want to live free or do
you not want to live freely like that's
the choice right now and those words i
mean send that clip around man you can
cut me out of it send that clip around
and and
this is a time tested battle that we're
in right now when he talks about the
children of israel in egypt when he
talks about christ on the cross this
thing has been fought before and it will
be fought again and what side are you on
well i know what side i'm on and i have
nothing better to do than save the world